welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition aka youtube's
number two
and this video we're breaking down how
time travel works in the umbrella
academy
the show is filled with a lot of timey
why me wibbly wobbly stuff
and throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down all of the timelines that
happen in it
and how the show avoids creating a
paradox
this is real heavy doc and because of
this there will be heavy spoilers
terrible puns and of course bad jokes
hopefully though you come away from this
video learning something
and if you do please hit the like button
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
with all out the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
breakdown
time travel it's one of the most
fascinating things in fiction
and over the years it's been used across
a wealth of media to tell a multitude of
stories
humanity is absolutely obsessed with it
and many have dedicated their entire
lives to trying to find a way to go back
and change things
the umbrella academy has used this
notion to great effect
and season two predominantly centers
around the hard greaves trying to avert
the apocalypse
by altering events in the past time
travel was first introduced
through number five and it's through him
that our video will predominantly center
after realizing he could teleport great
distances the character tried to hurtle
himself through time
and he actually succeeded in doing so
however
it wasn't all that it was cracked up to
be and after jumping too far
five found himself on the opposite side
of doomsday
unable to go back five and the world's
most beautiful mannequin
spent several decades in the barren
wasteland that was earth
and after several years of wandering he
was recruited by the thames commission
they stated that if he agreed to serve
them for five years
that he could retire to a time and place
of his choosing
and completely forget about all that had
gone on
though some things are too beautiful to
forget
five agreed to this but reneged on the
deal and instead traveled to his family
eight days before the apocalypse in
order to stop it from happening
due to miscalculating the time jump time
travelled through
five as he traveled through time and the
character ended up going back to his
younger body
he and his family tried to end
armageddon but they actually ended up
causing it
and season one ended on a big
cliffhanger with the world being
destroyed
now this creates a perfect loop in which
the future changes the past
and causes the events to happen in a way
that allows for the future too as well
thus in the first season we completely
avoid a paradox
and everything happens the way that it
was supposed to in the first place
however where things get a bit
complicated is that the group
actually jump back to the 60s and end up
altering events massively throughout the
course of the second season
now before we talk about the show and
how the timeline and it operates
we have to talk about time travel itself
it's something that theoretical
physicists have studied for generations
and predominantly the widely accepted
idea was that time travel was impossible
this is because of a theory known as the
grandfather paradox
this states that if one were to travel
back in time and kill their grandfather
before they were born
that their grandfather would never
create their parent thus
they would never be born and could not
travel back in time to kill their
grandfather in the first place
clearly the show does not operate like
this as there are major elements that
negate this being a possibility
the second theory that a lot of
physicists subscribe to
is called the bootstrap paradox this
states that
events in the future affect those in the
past and everything is a perfect loop
a good anecdote to explain this is that
say there's a scientist
one day whilst he's watching the heavy
spoilers show he hears a knock on the
door
no one's there but he finds a book on
his doorstep detailing how to build a
time machine
using this he creates one and then
travels to the future
the scientist takes the book with him
and leaves it on his own doorstep so
that
his past version can create the time
machine this creates a perfect loop
and it's something that was adapted by
the netflix show dark
up until about its third season which it
then segued into onyx way of thinking
now that is the many worlds theory now
in quantum physics
when you observe something this is often
known as taking a measurement
we'll be using the term quantum
measurement as this is sort of applied
across the board in this theory
now when we carry out a quantum
measurement on an electron
when we look at it we can see exactly
where it is
however before we look at it it could be
in a different position
and there are many possibilities to to
where it could have been before we
looked
in quantum physics this is known as a
superposition
as we don't know the exact place that it
is
so it could potentially be everywhere
this degree of varying possibilities
creates a number of alternatives known
as a wave function
and as all are valid and possible there
may be alternate realities
this was demonstrated in the
schrodinger's cat though experiment
which stated that before a particle is
measured it exists in all states at once
due to the statistical possibilities
that surround it however
once we observe it all the particles
come together
and form this one position so if we can
apply this thinking to electrons
which pretty much make up everything we
can of course apply it to absolutely
everything
thus if we place the cat in a box with a
radioactive substance that has
50 chance of killing and decaying it the
cat exists in both states of being alive
and dead
and it's only upon observing it or
rather measuring this state that we
see how it exists for us thus when
applied beyond the box
we realize that if this theory is
correct that everything exists in
multiple states of realities across
branching universes
in which every decision has a vast
degree of outcomes
that all alter a timeline from a certain
point
yes my head's exploding too now this is
what theory the umbrella academy
subscribes to
and you may have also seen it in
avengers end game in that the heroes
travel back to the past
and in altering it create branching
timelines so that nothing in the past
affects their own future tony stark even
drops the name of david deust
one of the many great thinkers behind
this notion and it's slowly becoming
more and more accepted as the main time
travel theory in that one can go back to
the past
but in doing so every choice they make
that alters it will create an alternate
world
because you can't change your past as
your present will always be
present it was also seen in that that
episode of community you know see
season three episode four with the the
dice anyway
the idea of alternate realities was
actually teased all the way back in
season one of the show
when we watched today namely march 29th
in which a completely different set of
events played out
that had a lot of different outcomes
namely namely allison and luther kissing
which
you know what i'm still rooting for you
guys now five changed this
and thus the timeline did no longer
remain as the main one
though it would have continued on in its
separate reality
this would have still led to the
apocalypse and thus
it becomes null and void past a certain
point now the next alternate timeline
that we see
happens at the start of season 2. we
learned that after vanya was taken in by
the fbi
her powers went into overload and she
destroyed their headquarters
just as jfk's motorcade was passing
because
vanya is russian and was suspected as a
spy the u.s declared war on the country
and the umbrella academy intervened
fighting in the battle
the russians deployed nukes to destroy
them which the u.s retaliated with
and thus the apocalypse happened once
more with the help of hazel
five traveled back and in doing so
created a brand new alternate timeline
in the 60s
which the second season predominantly
takes place in
now things get more complicated when he
meets his younger version
in the past this actually creates
another branching timeline
in which he sends himself back but
rather than being a young boy
he's an old man or his younger self now
it gets confusing look we don't know the
outcome of this timeline
but as five did not know the events in
the first season
other than it led to luther and five
traveling back to the 60s
he probably followed in the same
footsteps as they did taking the group
back there
after he failed to change things in the
future only this time he'd be
an older man now though i have seen some
people say that
the way the season ends is another
alternate reality on top of this
it's actually just a continuation of the
timeline that we saw play out in the 60s
the temps did promise to avert the
apocalypse and for better
or worse they did keep up their end of
the bargain now as vania being a member
of the academy is what led to armageddon
they may have altered several events to
change things and it is possible that
they even subliminally guided hog reeves
towards picking children that were not
powerful enough to end the world
this is why we see the sparrow academy
at the end with ben
who though not weak is certainly not
strong enough to destroy the planet
hargreaves is also alive in this
timeline possibly due to his family
sticking with him
instead of leaving like how the
hargreaves originally did
now we don't know where things will head
yet in the next season but
if the family jump once more they will
further fracture reality
and may even end up back in a timeline
in which the apocalypse still happens
i can't see them doing this and i think
this will be the reality that they
remain in as
it's the one place that we know for
definite things aren't going to go to
hell
though they might know now that these
guys are back now the temps did keep
their word
and alter events in a way in which the
world would not end and perhaps
you know this is the way that the events
need to happen in order to avoid all of
the realities in which armageddon was
the only outcome
in conclusion when we see time travel in
the show
we should take it as a group going back
and forth between alternate realities
which will continue on after they're
gone this allows everything to be a
possibility
but that doesn't necessarily mean it's
gonna be a positive outcome
maybe maybe we just have to accept that
the umbrella academy will always cause
the apocalypse
and if we want a real good time we have
to learn to love the sparrow academy
all hail hydra now that's our breakdown
of the time travel and timelines in the
show
i'm trying to make it as simple as
possible but if you have any questions
then make sure you leave them in the
comments below
and i or someone much smarter than me
will hopefully get back to you
if you want to learn more about the
sparrow academy then make sure you check
out our video linked at the end
as we go over who the main members are
and also give our theories on
how one of them may be an opposite to
number five don't forget that every
month on the 15th we give away free
blu-rays
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning the mcu infinity saga
box set
is leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on if you want to support
the channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you